hey guys what's going on this was a
chaotic week in the Bitcoin Market
because more details continue to surface
about the FTX Saga one thing that is
important is to separate out Bitcoin
from all of the centralized equity-based
exchanges why is that so important well
a couple of months ago if I had told you
that the second largest crypto exchange
was going to blow up implode and file
for bankruptcy I don't think very many
people would have thought that Bitcoin
was simply going to go sideways that
highlights how resilient the
decentralized peer-to-peer
software-based payment Network really is
at the end of the day Bitcoin and
decentralized platforms get lumped
together under the banner of the crypto
industry but Bitcoin is different some
of you will buy Bitcoin on the platforms
some of you will store your Bitcoin on
the platforms and others of you will try
to generate yield or use other financial
services that are provided by the
centralized services but ultimately
Bitcoin is a resilient separate thing
and I think the market is starting to
wake up to that that leads to the
conversation around regulation as we
have seen time and time again Bitcoin
already has a clear regulatory framework
both the SEC and the cfdc along with
Regulators around the world agree
Bitcoin is not a security Bitcoin will
continue to operate in the exact same
regulatory environment that it
previously was the big question and
where more regulatory scrutiny is going
to come is on centralized players and
the rest of the crypto industry I don't
know what the details will be I don't
know when that regulation will come but
it's hard for me to believe that 10
billion dollars potentially just
evaporated into the air and Regulators
won't step in and create tighter rules
lastly you have to remember that bear
markets suck everyone hates them they
don't feel good and naturally you kind
of wonder what the hell is going on but
bear markets are what Forge the
foundation for the next bull market as
we have seen Time and Time and Time
Again bear markets clear out the Bad
actors and they clear out the bad
businesses this is how free market
dynamics should work and it's exactly
what we're seeing happen in real time
bear markets are a necessary part of the
market cycle and I believe that once we
get to the other side of this the
industry the assets and the players will
be stronger for it that's it for this
week I hope that you enjoy these weekly
updates and I'll see you all next
Saturday